senin erkeğin elinin kınası kadının
yüzünün karısı Aman kızım beyni vermiş
de Kız kızlığını vermemiş dikkat et ORT
kızın bacağını adet gördüğün artık
sokakta oynayamazsın bak erkekler Tek
bir şeyin peşindedir Kızlığın alırlar
Ondan sonra seni kullanır atarlar
bırakır giderler adın çıkacağına canı
çıksın diye diye büyütülen kız
çocuklardan biri olarak gün
apartmanımızın bahçesinde oynuyorum eve
45 40 son bir yaşında falanız şöyle bir
duvar var o Duvara çıkıyoruz atlıyoruz
çıkıyoruz atlıyoruz oynadığımız oyunda
bu çok eğleniyoruz derken yukarıdan bir
ses kızaklama bakayım kızınız patlar
Nasıl yani Şehrin en işlek caddesinde
dördüncü kat
İyi teyze aşağıya sesleniyor ve şehre
kızımız hakkında bir fikir veriyor Hani
yasaktı hanıma hanima hem de Bizim
kızımız buz gibi oluyoruz çok utanıyoruz
kız arıyoruz ama balkondan içeri
girdiğinde Havva teyze Oyuna devam
ediyoruz bir Havva teyze ile maceralarım
çoktur çok güzel kısır yapar evine
çağırır kısır yemeğe gideriz tabağımıza
doldururuz tam limon uzandık Kızlar siz
sıkmayın bakayım limon neden Ama teyze
kızınız erir fazla kurcalamayın Oranı
buranı zı boncuğunu Dışarıdan çok
bilirim Böylece boncuğu bir yerde
düşürdün mü bu boncuk nasıl bir şey ne
olunca düşüyor içimizde bir organ var
dokunamıyor Uz hakkında biz
konuşamıyoruz hakkında herkes
konuşabiliyor bu patlıyor bazen bazen
eriyor bazen de boncuk döküyoruz Ama bu
genelde Havva teyze ile bir aradayken
oluyor bizim evde çok olmuyor böyle
tabularla büyük büyüyerek bugünlere
geliyoruz tablo
O çok ikiyüzlüdür toplumsal cinsiyete
çok ikiyüzlüdür bir yerde yasaklar
vardır bir yerde de ulu orta
Konuşulanlar vardır Bu Kadar Çok baskı
altında Büyüyünce ben de bu huyunu
seviyorum biraz baskılara ve tabulara
karşı içinde İsyan bayrağı açan bir
taraf var o zaman dedim ki ben işte bu
kızlık bozuluyor bir bunu bozuyor biri
alıyor Bu birilerine verdiğimiz bir şey
ve mahrem bir şey madem bu kadar kutsal
bir şey ben bunu kimseye vermeyeceğim Bu
kızı kimseye yar etmeyeceğim ve asla
evlenmeyeceğim diyorum annem daha bile
Çeyiz yapıyor ya habire dantel yapıyor
yatak odasına perde örüyor işte böyle
çarşaflar falan onlara dantel örüyor
diyorum ki örme istemiyorum Çünkü ben
evleneceğim O da diyor ki Tamam sen
evlenme ama ben çeyizini yapayım sonra
çeyiz yapmadı deme kavga gürültü filan
diyorum ki yani evlenmeyeceğim Ama
evlenirsem de gelinlik giymeyeceğim
biraz
bir varlık ediyorum yani çünkü çok kolay
bir şey değil bu tabulara karşı dur bak
öyle de yaptım demek isterdim yapamadım
toplam iki kere evlendim iki şerden
dörder kere gelinlik giydim Çünkü
tablolarla bireysel değil birleşerek
mücadele edilebilir Öyle kolay değil
tabulara kafa tutmak ama en azından şunu
başarabilmiş Team ilk evliliğimden
Boşanmış ve bir kızım varken tırnak
içinde dul bir kadın Ken yeniden
evlenebilmek iş ve yeniden kendime bir
hayat vadede binmiştim Bu benim ikinci
eşim ve yine tablolar varsa bir
görüyorsunuz ki Türk annesi Düğüne
gideceğiz ama çocuk aç çocuğa yemek
yedirmeye çalışıyoruz tipik bir Türk
Annesi önce çocukta olsun Ondan sonra
Düğüne gideriz yani tabulara meydan
okumak için toplumsal olarak Hepimiz
birlikte mücadele etmeliyiz Çünkü
tabular ikiyüzlüdür Birçok genç kız
küçük çocuk işte benim kendi Örneğin
dedi anla
O henüz adet görmek nasıl bir şey
Bununla ilgili bile sağlıklı bir
yarışmaz Ken bekâret kavramıyla kızı
kavramı ile tanışıyor ve Korkular
içerisinde dehşet içerisinde büyüyor
adet demişken böyle reklamlarda
görüyoruz Path reklamları oluyor hep bir
Mavi kan var dikkatimizi çekiyor mu bu
sizin yani limonlu eriyor mavi kalıyoruz
uzaylı mıyız Biz ne oluyoruz tamamen bir
çarpıtılan kadın cinselliği ile ilgili
yanlış bilgilendirilen bir sistem var ya
da Path alışverişine gideceksiniz
bilmiyorum Ben küçük yerde büyüdüm hala
büyük yerlerde belki olmasa da küçük
yerlerde bunun geçerli olduğunu
biliyorum market ya da bakalım GTA
almaya gittiğinizde utana sıkıla
alırsınız dili öğretmeni falan
görürseniz Pide bırakır biraz oy
alınırsınız sanki uyuşturucu madde
kaçakçılığı yapıyorsunuz kasada sonra
yanına bir şeyler de alırsınız dedim ve
o pedi sarmamız gerekir ki görmesinler
Neden Çünkü
Ne görürse mağazalar bir rahminiz
olduğunu ve kaldığınızı anlar Neden
Çünkü kadın cinselliği Tabu dur çocuk
bizi aldığınızda ya da bir başka
alışveriş yaptığınızda aynı şey aynı
şekilde saklama gereksinimi
hissetmezsiniz Örneğin bir tuvalet
kağıdı ona da özel bölgelerini
temizliyorsunuz ama kadın cinselliği
için geçerli olan kitaplar vardır ve
bunlar Herkes tarafından Aslında
dillendirilmesi de bilinir bu tabularla
büyürken Bir taraftan da mücadele
ederken kendimi yetiştirirken kendimde
de çok fazla adlı bu olduğunu farkettim
Aslında her ne kadar muhalif gibi dursam
da bunu a psikiyatrist olarak
psikoterapist olarak çalıştığında
kendine yakında her defasında şaşırdım
bunlardan bir tanesi 2014 yılında
uluslararası seksoloji birliği ve Avrupa
83 Birliği ülkemize geldi ve burada Hem
bir kongre düzenlendi hem de
Uluslararası bir
e-portal bir sınav düzenlendi ve bu
sağdan geçtiğinizde Avrupa onaylı olarak
yeni bir unvan alıyorsunuz Uluslararası
bir seks terapisi olabiliyorsunuz ama
çok heyecanlandım biraz da kendimden
eminim kaç yıllık psikiyatrist ve
psikoterapist üzeri Bilişsel davranışçı
terapi eğitmeliyim biliyorum ben bunu
giderim ama bu sınavı geçerim diye
düşünüyorum gitti üç günlük bir kamp
süreci var bu kadar bu kadar kitaplar
yüzlerce sayfası Lite ve bir sürü ders
gördük böyle yabancı hocalar falan
gelmişti bir çok şaşırdım O kadar az şey
bildiğimiz fark ettim ki özellikle kadın
cinselliği ile ilgili ve bilgili
çalışmak zorunda kalma ve sonuçta borcu
geçtim ve akredite oldu ama evi soru
bakalım Nasıl olduk Çünkü yüzleştiğim
tarafların çok enteresan da bir gün
Hollandalı bir hoca 70 yaşlarında kadın
cinselliği ile ilgili bir şey anlatırken
bir ekranı bir görüntü yansıttı bir
kadın bir erkeğe oral seks yapıyordu ve
salonda bir anda buz gibi bir
iki yabancı katılımcılar da vardı
kursiyerler arasında herkes başını önüne
eğdi Tabii ben de utanmış tık soracağız
iki Evet ne oldu şimdi içinizden
olduğuna bakın utandığınız değil mi yani
biz cinsel Terapist falan diye Gittik
oralara ama utanç hepimizin içinde olan
bir şey ve bununla çalışmak Belki bir
ömür boyu uğraşmak gerekecek ve kendi
tarafımı yakalamış olmak benim hoşuma
gittim daha sonra o yıllarda
muayenehaneye açtım ve biraz da cinsel
terapistin Yani ben kadın Doktorum
avantaj bana daha çok kadınlar gelir
zaten ben de keyif alıyorum kadınlarda
çalışmaktan oyna güzel kadın Kadın
çalışır gideriz diye düşünüyorum telefon
geldi o zaman sekreterim de yok yalnız
Çalışıyorum aşkım telefonu doktorun hem
sertleşme sorunum var kesin çözüm
bulabiliyorsunuz ben size geleceğim
kesin çözüm hiçbir şeyde tıpta yoktur
ama ben elimden geleni yapalım Buyurun
gelin Neyse geldi Bütün danışanlara bir
soruyoruz genelde işte Neden biz
Evet hepinize dedim Recep'in tercih
ettiğiniz bir çocuğum kadın olduğumuz
için Allah Allah Dedim acaba neden evde
biraz açar mısınız dedi ki hocam Zaten
yan ilanımız düşmüş herhalde bunu gidip
bir başka erkeğe anlatacak değiliz Madam
edeceğimizi Doktor hanım ikimiz kendi
aramızda konuşuruz aramızda kalır
hallederiz dedi Neden Çünkü halk
arasında cinsel işlev bozukluğu
erkeklerde ne deniyor iktidarsızlık
geliyor Çünkü cinsellik karşılıklı keyif
adını verilen paylaşılan bir şey
olmaktan çoktan çıkmış toplumsal
cinsiyet normları tarafından erkeğin
iktidarı iktidar olduğunu Güç gösterisi
becerdi bir şey olmuş kadının da edin
olduğu maruz kaldığı bir şey olmuş E
zaten ben bir kadın olarak iktidar
alanında olmadığım için iki
iktidarsızlık güzel güzel çalışıyorsun
iktidarını geri iade için o gidecek öyle
düşünüyorum Yanlış anlama o kadar çok
şey öğrendim ki Öykü alırken soruyorum
diyorum ki peki diyorum bu yaşadığınızı
sen bunları nasıl yansıyor
ilişkilerinize nasıl yazıyor bu sorumuz
hocam de vallahi biz kahvede konuşuruz
şimdi yok Mehmet Mesela bir tanımla her
gece iki kere yapıyoruz diyor Ben
diyorum ki ben hiç kere yapıyorum
diyorum o Sen altı aydır yaş kullanarak
ilişkiye giremiyorum eşimle yüzüne Şimdi
bundan haberi yok Yani bir sorun yaşıyor
ve en yakının bundan haberi yok Peki
kahvede Bunlar konuşuyorlar şimdi bu
adamlar birbirine gitseler senin hanım
nasıl cinsellikle falan desene kan çıkar
ama ben gece iki kere yapıyorum üç kere
yapıyorum derken bahsettikleri kişi kim
eşlerin toplumsal cinsiyet ve tabular
işte böyle ikircikli ikiyüzlü bir şeydir
ve Tabi ben de kişilerde çalışırken hem
kendi tabularımı farkedip hem onların
hayatlarına dokunabilmek hem de biraz
model olabilmek fırsatı bulabildim zaman
içerisinde aşkı kendime yıkıldım
tabulardan bir ta
Evet evet tadı danışanlara çalışırken
olan Çünkü kadınlar geceler diye
düşünüyorum Terapiye yani benim öyle bir
sorunum var biraz konuşalım mı derler
değil Kadınlar cinsel ihtiyaçların
gereksinimlerinin neredeyse farkında
değiller ya zaten onu bir görev olarak
yapıyorlar ben genelde yere konuşuyorum
Tabii ki herkes için geçerli ama böyle
bir genel bilgi var Eğer vajinusmus
dediğimiz ilişkiye girememe durumu varsa
o zaman geliyorlar Çünkü şöyle bir durum
oluyor evleniyorlar kayınvalide ya da
kendi annesi gelin ya da damadın arıyor
diyor ki oldu mu iş yapabildiniz mi
yapamadı ise Allah böyle toplanıp 156
kişi falan muayeneniz de gelebilirler
artık o birisi haline geliyor Aile
meselesi haline gelebiliyor Bunun
dışında kadınların çok fazla cinsel
terapi için başvurduklarını görmüyorum
başka konularla başvurduktan ilgili
başvurduktan sonra süreç ilerledikçe
şöyle bir şey oluyor ya benim şöyle bir
sorunum var
Ya ben aslında yani biraz Utanıyorum
bunu biliyor olmam lazım ama bilmiyorum
siz bana bu konuda yardımcı olabilir
misiniz dediği konular Aslında çoğumuzun
bilmediği Benim de 35 yaşlarında belki
işte gittiğim bir çok eğitim den
öğrendiğim Hatta hala öğrenmeye devam
ettiğim konular oluyor Çünkü kadınlar
Aslında yeni Bilgisizlik lerinden dolayı
değil Toplumsal olarak bu bilgilere
erişim ortadan kaldırıldığı için
bilmiyorlar en çok bilgi eksikliği olan
konular orgazm mastürbasyon ve bekâret
ile ilgili konularda oluyor kadın
cinselliğini ne kadınlar ne de erkekler
bilmiyor Peki neden bilmiyorlar İşte
anlattım atlıyorsun patlıyor eriyor
böyle yaşıyorsun erkekler yani oğlan
çocukları nasıl yetiştiriliyor
Bilmiyorum siz Aşina mısınız Ben
bulunduğum bölgede bunlara çok sağlık
oldum Hala da görüyorum hiç çok genç
delikanlı daha Reşit
ve kişisel deneyimlerine genelevlerde ve
seks işçileriyle denir ve toplumda bunu
olan karşılıyor kimse demiyor ya bu
çocuklar 18 yaş altında ve bu çocuk
istismarı demiyor erkeğin deneyimiz
makbul nerede deneyim kazanacak kızlara
yasam Demek ki orada deneyim kazanacak
bundan bazen şeye benzetiyorum Hayır
bebekleri büyütürken belli eş 6 aydan
sonra ek gıdaya geçeriz küçük küçük
gıdaları tanıtırız ki alerjik
reaksiyonlar oluşmasın bağışıklık
kazansın diye erkek çocukları sağlıyoruz
bir adaya ya yeni istediğiniz meyveleri
doya doya çıkarım hayatım kızlara
Diyoruz ki ama sakın yapma ölürsün
ağzını bile süreceksin bu meyvelere
sonra eğleniyorlar diyelim ki Bir kız
bir oğlan ve ki buyurun koca bir tabak
meyve ve doya doya yine bu kızın bundan
zevk almasını ve alerji geliştirmesini
bekliyoruz böyle bir şey Mümkün değil
yıllarca yasakladığı bir şeyi sonra
birdenbire çok olan tur etmesini
bekleyemezsin toplu
ve bu konuda da ikiyüzlüdür ve kadınlar
çok az konuşuyorlar erkeklerden
cinselliğim birçok kadın cinsellikten
korkutuyor Çünkü hurafelerle
büyütüyorlar cinsellik konusunda bilgi
geldi bedenleri konusunda bilgi sahibi
mi kadınlar dediğimizde Aslında çok
kadın değil klitorisi duyan varmı
aranızda bilmiyorum ama çok kadın
Klitoris nedir nerede bulunur ne işe
yarar bilmiyor Çünkü inancı yüzyıllardan
kadın cinselliğinin haz merkezi olan
sadece cinsel haz vermeye yarayan
kritoris unutulmuş nasıl unutulmuş Grup
insan erkek bir araya gelmiş bir bunun
kadın için gerekli olmadığına karar
vermişler ve anatomi Atlas larından
silmiş Hatta kadınların sünnet etmişler
bugün hala günümüzde şu an hayatta olan
200 milyon Kız Çocuğu sünnet edilmiş
durumda 30 milyon da risk altında tamam
bizim ülkemizde sünnet edilen kızlar yok
krizi tamamen
Bu Kızlar yok belki ama zihinsel olarak
sünnet edilmiş iz bilmiyoruz O bölgemize
yok sayıyoruz bunun en büyük
sorunlarından bir tanesi Ford 1900'lü
yıllarda Freud kültürü ile ilgili şöyle
demiş kadının orijinal sı cinsel
organıdır bu orijinal orgazma budur bir
tören orgaz İlkel bir şeydir klitoris
Paris olamamış artık bir organdır demiş
ve kuyuya bir taş atmış o günden bugüne
de pek çok kadın vajinal olarak orgaz
olamadığında kendisini hasarlı ve sorunu
zannediyor 18 sadece on kadından 3'ü
ho-jin al yolu orgazm olabilirken diğer
kadınlar 7'si başka yollarla orgazm
oluyor ve eğer ki bir kadın her
seferinde orgazm olduğunu söylüyorsa o
kadının beşinin sırf sorun çıkmasın sırf
normal görürsün ya da eşi mutlu olsun
farkları mutlu olsun diye orgazm
numarası yaptığını söyleyebiliriz
Bu kilitorus Nasıl yok edilmiş birinci
resimde gördüğünüz gibi üste bir çıkıntı
var ikinci resimde o küçük bir nokta CIA
dönüştürülmüş gitgide silikleştirme iş
gerçekten anlatım atlasından çıkarılmış
şöyle söyleyeyim penisi olanlar için
Mesela bir gün geliyoruz Diyoruz ki Biz
Kadınlar toplandık karar verdik sizin
penisiniz İlkay doğru buradan zevk
almanız canlan sız Biz bunu unutmanız
istiyoruz dokunmayacaksın ızel
yemeyeceksiniz penis ile ilgili bir şey
yapmayacaksınız Siz dizimizin zevk
alacaksınız bundan sonra eğer ki bizden
zevk alamıyorsanız da bu İlkel bir şey
size bir sorum var bunu geliştirmeye
çalışın cep yani kritolis ile ilgili
olan hikaye böyle bir bakalım Klitoris
nasıl bir organ bize hep bu soldaki gibi
gösterilir sizin sağınızda kadın cinsel
organı değil mi ama aslında orada
kocaman baktığınızda düğme gibi olup
içeriye doğru bu kocaman olan bir
bu devam ediyor Bu sizin klitorisin iz
bunu tanıyın bilgi güçtür bilginin
değilseniz tabular sizi ele geçirir ve
sizin cinselliğin izi sizden çalarlar
Eğer ki size bir bozukluk olduğunu
düşünüyorsanız lütfen bunun hakiki
bozukluk olup olmadığını araştırın iki
Bununla ilgili nereden başlayabiliriz
Lütfen bir ayna alın elinize ve cinsel
bölgelerini inceleyelim kendinizi
tanıyın çok kadına fotoğrafları çeksek
bir grup cinsel bölgenin ve fotoğrafları
göstersek bu Hangisi sizin cinsel
bölgenin desek neredeyse bilemeyecek
leri kadar o bölgeyi yoksa yiyorlar O
nedenle lütfen kendinize dokunun
kendinizi tanıyın ve parmaklarınızı
lütfen kullanın klitorisini onurlandırır
demek istiyorum Bilgisizlik suçluluk
utanç size empoze edilen bir şey bunun
üstlenmek zorunda değil
da başka türlü bir cinsellik başka türlü
bir bağ kurmak mümkün tabular tek başına
yenilecek şeyler değildir Havva teyzeler
Hüseyin Amcalar hepsi birer Sembol
toplumsal Cinsiyetin sesi Onlar ne zaman
bir sesimiz onlardan daha gür
çıkarabiliriz O zaman bu tavırların
üstesinden gelebiliriz ve giyersek ne
içersek hangi bölgemizden zevk alırsak
cinselliği nasıl deneyimler Sekin sal
yönetimimiz Neyse istiyorsak
istemiyorsak birleşmek istiyorsak sadece
sevişmek Sadece sarılıp yatmak istiyorsa
karne istiyorsak buna hakkımız var
Cesaret bulaşıcıdır Biz Benden her zaman
büyüktür değişim sizin elinizde hem de
parmaklarınızın ucunda lütfen kullanın
ve bunun keyfini çıkarın Unutmayın ki
herkesin hayatına kimse karışamaz az